قال بيان وقمه النيتو في يومها الاول في
العاصمه الليتوانيه ان الحلفة سيكون في
وضع يسمح بتوجيه دعوه الى اوكرانيا
للانضمام الى النيتو عندما يتفق الحلفاء
ويتم استيفاء الشروط واضف بيان القمه لا
يسعى الى المواجهه ولا يشكل اي تهديدا
لروسيا لكن في ضوء سياسات موسكو وافعالها
العدائيه لا يمكن اعتبار روسيا للحلف هذا
وكان قد اجتمع قاده حلف شمال الاطلسي في
العاصمه الليتوانيه في قمه هامه تستمر
ليومين لمناقشه ملفات الدعم لاوكرانيا
والانفاق الدفاعي وقال الناتو نقادته 31
يجتمعون في لحظه حرجه للامن عبر المحيط
الاطلسي وبدات قمه النيتو بزخم جديد بعد
ان اعلنت انقره موافقتها على البدء في
اجراءات التصديق على عضويه السويد في
الحلف
بنجربه قال الامين العام لحلف في شمال
الاطلسي ان دعوة اوكرانيا لعضويه الحلف
ستكون فقط في حاله استكمالها الشروط
المطلوبه واوضح في مؤتمر صحفي عاقبه
مناقشات في اليوم الاول من قمه النيتو في
ليتوانيا ان الدعوه ستواجه الى اوكرانيا
للانضمام الى النيتو عندما يتفق الحلفاء
واشار الى ان هناك حزمه مساعدات قويه
لاوكرانيا ومسارا واضحا عضويتها في الحلف
مؤكدا ان الناتو مفتوح امام الاعضاء وهم
من يقررون توسيع عضويته وليس موسكو وفق
تعبير